[Alkış]
sizce en iyi eğitim veren üniversiteler
hangileri Stanford Oxford
mı biliyor musunuz Bence bunlardan
hiçbiri Çünkü benim için en iyi
üniversite
internet Peki eğitim nedir eğitim sözlük
manası itibariyle bir insanın
davranışını istendik yönde değiştirme
sürecidir
ben anadolu öğretmen lisesindeyim liseye
girdiğimizde bize ilk öğretilen
nokta bir insanı bizim istediğimiz
şekilde nasıl değiştirirsin oldu bunu
kavrayabilmek sene mi aldı ve aklım
başına geldiğinde ben ne yapıyorum dedi
o dönemler yazılım ve Siber güvenliğe
ilgi duydum onun üzerine bir şeyler
yapmaya çalıştım ama Kimse buna Destek
çıkmadı Ne ailem
ne arkadaşlarım ne de Müdürüm Hatta bir
kere Müdürüm dedi ki senin yaşın
kaç bilgisayar Okuyup ne
yapacaksın bilgisayar okuyanları
görüyoruz tüm Buna karşın ben yılmadım
ve bir şekilde bırakma bırakma kararını
aldım Aslında Bir bakıma da sanırım
zorunda kaldım Çünkü 2 sınıfın 1ci
dönemi 8 tane zayıfım vardı Halbuki ben
Türkiye 20c liği ile yerleşmişti bu
okula
Okuldan ayrıldım düz liseye
geçtim İroni şudur ki birinci dönem
sınıfta kalacak Ken 8 zayıfla birlikte
ikinci dönem takdir
alıyordum Okuldan ayrıldım ve iş
hayatına atıldım ilk iş görüşmem çok
ilginçti
Unutamadım gittim Neler yapabiliyorsun
dedi bunları yapabiliyorum dedim Ne
bekliyorsun dedi şunu bekliyorum dedim
yeteneklerim de bunlar dedim ama
dikkatimi şu çekti hiçbir şekilde bana
sen nereden mezun oldun diploma nerede
gibi sorular almadı Halbuki burada
hepinizin aklında diploma diploma
diploma diye geçiyordur muhtemel ama
bana böyle bir şey
sormadılar işe başladın Bir gün
Ofisteyim
Oturuyorum Facebook'ta dolaşırken bir
reklam gördüm diyordu ki sınav puanı
dikkate makın Üniversiteye giriş imkanı
yeteneklerine hayallerine ve projelerine
göre bir durdum ve algılamaya çalıştım
çünkü ben böyle bir şeyin ihtimal
vermiyordum Hiç yoktan
Türkiye'de siteye girdim kayıt olmaya
çalıştım kaydı da basıyorum Basıyorum
olmuyor bir şekilde kaydımı
ekleyemiyorum o zaman şöyle
dedim Madem
ki yetenek ve hayallere göre burs alan
burs veren bir sistem neden yeteneğimi
göstermiyorum
dedim okulun sistemini
ekledim kendi kaydımı ekledim ve kendime
tam burs
verdim bunu da videoya çekip okula mail
olarak gönderdim diğer gün
aradılar dediler ki tüm bölümlerde tam
bursum var bizim okula
gelebilirsin Belki de eğitime bu kadar
karşı olmakla beraber İlk defa bu kadar
çok
sevinmiştim Çünkü yeni bir hayat
başlıyordu benim
için üniversiteye geldiğimde
ise ben o sene Barajı geçemedim tam
bursum var ama Barajı geçemedim ben
ÖSYM'ye göre başarısız bir
öğrenciydim hiçbir üniversiteye girmeyi
hak
etmiyordum Bir sene daha hazırlandım
2 sene Barajı geçtim ilk yaptığım şey
ÖSYM'ye tweet atmak
oldu dedim ki beni sistemin kölesi
yapamadınız Altına da Pink floyd'un
Another brings Wall şarkısını ekledim ve
gönderdim çünkü videonun klibinde
unutamadığım bir şey vardı eğitim
sistemini bir makineye benzetiyordu
öğrenciler tek tek
giriyordu çıktıklarında ise
birer kuklayı robot gibiydiler işte Tam
da bizim eğitim
sistemimiz bu gibi ben buna benzetiyorum
Çünkü bize robot üretmeyi öğretmiyorlar
bize
robotlaşmak sonra ösm tarafından
engellendim bir nevi Aslında sevgili
tribi
yedim Öyle ki şu eğtim sistemi insanları
tek tipleştirme yönelik
kurulmuş küt kesilmiş bir eldiven
düşünün aldınız elinize koydunuz ne
olur kimileri için eğitim sistemi az
gelirken
kimilerine fazla geliyor ama herkesten
aynı düzeyde ve tek tip bir şekilde
çıktı
istiyorlar ama ne yazık ki herkes buna
uygun olmuyor Ben ÖSYM in başarısız
görmesine karşın tambursuz bir şekilde
okula
girdim sanırım tamamıyla şansım yaver
gitmedi yetenek konusunda Çünkü bir
dönemler ben bankalarla çok fazla
ilgileniyordum Açıklar bulmaya
çalışıyordum bir ara bir açık buldum ATM
nettik cihazlarında
geçerliydi düşünün ki kredi kartı
bilgilerini geçin kişisel bilgilere
kadar erişim sağlanıyordu
bunu raporladı
ve gönderdim 3 ay sonra geri dönüş
yaptılar aradılar dediler ki ya Teşekkür
ederiz sayenizde açığımızı kapattık
sistemimizi yeniledik ve bunu
karşılıksız bırakmayacağız Şimdi
soruyorum size Türkiye'nin en büyük
bankalarından birisi size böyle bir şey
söyledi ne
beklersiniz beş yıldızlı bir otel tablet
bilgisayar ya da iş ben acaba bir iş mi
teklif edecekler diye bir düşündüm
Ama onların verdiği hediye çok
manidardı iki kişilik sinema bileti
hediye
ettiler Evet evet bir değil iki kişilik
sinema bileti hediye ettiler Ben de
neden iki kişi gideyim ki dedim onlar da
insan Onların da hakkı var dedim bana
gönderdikleri bilet firmasını hackleyip
100 tane bilet aldım Buyurun hep
birlikte gidelim diye de karşılık
verdim şansım üniversite girdikten sonra
döndü
Aslında üniversiteye girdim işte birçok
yeni insanlarla tanıştım birçok yeni
vizyonla tanıştım aynı kafadan insanlar
da
vardı birlikte bir şeyler yapmaya
başladık O dönemler sosyal medyayla
Twitter'la çok fazla
uğraşıyordu Twitter'da bir açık bulduk
açık sayesine düşünün ki Herhangi bir
insanın şifresini ele geçirebiliyor
musunuz veya banka bilgisine erişim
sağlayabiliyorsunuz veya daha ilerisini
düşünün
kime eklerdiniz
Twitter'ın kurucusu Jack dorsey Bill
Gates ya da
Rihanna Biz hiçbirini yapmadık mail
formatı hazırladık raporladı ve
raporumuzu
gönderdik dönüşümüz de aldık ödülümüz de
aldık Aradan birkaç ay geçti ve bir gün
sizin de girdiğiniz ağ kapısından
çıktığımızda bir mail geldi aldım elemim
telefonu baktım ne diye İngilizce bir
mail'i
tek anlayabildiğim Twitter San Francisco
ve davet Bu arada benim İngilizcem zayıf
hala daha
hazırlıktayken
Twitter'dan davet
almışsın bir çekildim durdum Çünkü benim
en büyük hayallerimden birisiydi silikon
vadisine gitmek San Francisco görmek
Belki de birçok yazılımcının
Hayallerinden birisidir
inanmayıp diğer arkadaşıma da
gösterdiğimde aynı cevabı alınca Demek
ki Evet ben bir adım daha ilerledim dedi
ve San francisco'ya gittik arkadaşımla
beraber bir etkinliğe davet
edilmişti şunu gördüm orada Şimdi sağıma
bakıyorum veya soluma bakıyorum 1617
yaşında gençler sizin çocuk diyeceğiniz
kişiler çıkartıyor konuşuyoruz
çıkartıyor kartını veriyor üzerinde CE
ve cofounder
yazıyor Türkiye'ye döndükten sonra şunu
sorguladım Jack dorsey Twitter'ın
kurucusu O da diğer Milyoner arkadaşları
gibi Okulu
bırakmış Neden peki özellikle teknoloji
alanında ilgilenen insanların Okulu
bırakmasını sorguladım ve şu sonuca
vardım pratik kavramları geliştirmeyen
eğitim
sistemi teoriye dönmemiş bir hipotez
gibidir
biraz da aslında şuna benzettim Ben bunu
bir dizi izliyordum element adı altında
orada Tavan Arası teorisini anlatıyordu
ve şöyle bir örnek veriyordu iki tane
bardağı alıyordu İkisinde de su var
birisinde daha fazla var ve diyordu ki
bu senin beynin belli bir kısım içindeki
su da ihtiyacın olan bilgiler yani
ihtiyacın diğerinde ise gerçekten
gerekli bilgiler şimdi bir
tarafta gerekli veya gereksizi
tartışabilmek baz
alaktan öğrencileri yargılıyor bizleri
yargılıyor ve bu yüzden ne yazık ki
yaratıcılığı öldürüyoruz Umut dug
törpülüyor merak diye bir şey ortada
kalmıyor benim içinse merak başarının
motorudur düşün nasıl ki hani arabayı
çalıştırmak için anahtarı çevirmeniz
motoru çalıştırmanız gerekir ya işte
benim için merak böyle bir şey ama bizim
eğitim sistemimiz öyle yapmıyor bizim
eğitim sistemimiz arkadan geliyor
arabayı ittirmek le meşgul direksiyonla
başkalarının
elinde Umuyorum ki ve istiyorum ki artık
o merak duygusunu
uyandırsın bıraksınlar ki o anahtarı
çevirelim O motorumuz çalışsın ve
direksiyon bizim elimizde olsun Çünkü o
zaman biz daha ileriye gideceğiz O zaman
biz daha başarılı
olacağız
teşekkürler